you have time at 34 years old when I
started vaynermedia and now it's vaynerx
and at the revenue we're at it's a
billion dollar company if I was to sell
it today it's a big ass [__] company
that's what I actually do when
everyone's like what does garyvee
actually do is he what the [__] is he
doing like do you not know that I run a
1500 person Global office I have a real
company like garyvee is my side hustle
Gary vaynerchuk runs an actual business
but when I started Vayner when I was 34
years old because I was building my
dad's business and because in family
business you don't get paid I had no
[__] money I started vaynermedia in
buddy media's conference room because I
didn't want to have any rent fee at 34.
if you're sitting and watching right now
and you're 28 and you don't have [__]
you can get [__] just because you're 31
but your buddy's making a million on
nfts or your best friend's girls making
4 million on Tick Tock you don't have to
feel like a piece of [__] we're in the
first quarter just because you're not
winning at 23 or 27 or 32 you're not
finished and by the way what's winning
when is it time to panic 70